And then let's check in quickly with Alex.
Who interrupts Alex?
Who interrupts what's going on today?
Oh Hey David.
Hey.
Um, I'm curious cause I saw a video you did
about like with the Democrats, your, um, of
presidential candidates.
You were asking who can win, like you're asking
about when ability, and it reminded me of
the 2016, um, the, during the Republican primary,
there are Republicans that were asking the
same thing.
And My, my question was like, if it's just
about defeating Hillary Clinton, you know,
the probable nominee, like what is the purpose
of the Republican Party?
Cause if it's just about winning than if it's
a sport.
Right.
So I mean my, my question is for, for Democrats
now, what is the purpose of the Democrat Party?
Well, I don't think, um, I don't think Democrats
see defeating Trump as merely sport to check
a win on, you know, to get a check on the
wind column rather than the last column.
I think that Democrats see that basically
any of the possible candidates would be an
improvement.
I'm s I'm, I'm speculating here.
I think that if you asked Democratic voters,
they would say any of the 20 plus people running
would be better than Trump.
So it's not about getting a win for sport,
it's that we just think whoever replaces Trump
from the possible candidates is going to be
an improvement.
Okay.
Well my question is still is what is the purpose
of the Democrat Party?
The Democratic Party, like the Republican
Party wants to hold seats in elected government
so that they can advance their agenda.
Okay.
What is their agenda?
Well, I mean I don't know that you need me
to list it and includes a $15 minimum wage
and includes the increasing access to health
care includes reducing inequality.
It includes green energy.
I mean it did.
I, you don't need me to list that.
That's online.
But each party has an agenda which they want
to advance by winning races.
Right.
Okay.
So I mean they have all these things that
they want, right.
And the, they're going to achieve it.
How
the same way Republicans would achieve it
by taking control of the Senate, taking control
of the White House and passing bills.
Okay.
I mean I get, it's your, you're saying their,
their goal is to change the country.
I am.
My question is how is, how is what they want
different, they have different policy priorities
than Republicans, but like they both understand
how politics works, right?
You got to win races and then your people
are in power and then they make decisions.
Right.
Understood.
And with your previous call, he was asking
like, why aren't people marching in the streets?
Yeah.
I'm asking him to like impeach Trump.
And it's kind of ironic you were saying, oh,
it's because they're too employed.
No, that's not, you completely misunderstood
what it is.
What I said is when you have a system in which
there is such disproportionate power and economic
stability between the rich and corporations
and the mass, the mass of the workers, you
put them in a situation where they cannot
afford their economic situation.
It's so precarious.
They cannot afford to even take a day off
or to travel to an urban center to mass rally
or whatever the case.
I think you may be misunderstood deliberately
or accidentally what I said.
Okay.
Well, um, I, I see it as their, they have
a job, so maybe that's why they are not calling
for impeachment.
Yeah.
All right, Alex, we just disagree, but I appreciate
you not interrupting today.
You did a really good job.
Okay, thanks.
Thanks.
Yep.
All right.
That's it for Alex at tipper live calls for
today.
A lot of important stories to get to right
after the break.